we have a voicemail number the number is
two one nine two david p here's a
question that came in overnight hey
david this is keith from louisiana I'm
just calling about this the right using
this term angel parents for family
members of people who have been killed
by undocumented immigrants I'm just
curious
where this started from what your
thoughts are about this and what it's
supposed to even mean if these are
supposed to be seen as like messengers
from God I don't really understand the
symbolism just curious about your
thoughts on that
thanks it's a propaganda term I mean
yeah angel mom's there's it's anyone who
loses a child has suffered but just an
unimaginable hardship and grief and it's
a tragedy and the idea of saying that if
you lost the child because of the action
of an undocumented immigrant then you
are designated an angel mom or an angel
parent it's it's a propaganda term and
it's actually catching on and it seems
to be working pretty well for them we
have a great bonus show for you today
hope you'll join me by either becoming a
member or a patron I'll see you then